voilà cinq ans que montigny le
bretonneux a décidé de prendre la route
du zéro phyto ce pesticide est un vrai
problème sanitaire selon une étude du
ministère de la santé
il est à l'origine de cancers de
troubles de la reproduction ou encore la
maladie de parkinson
il a fallu revoir effectivement toutes
les pratiques parce que traiter c'est
facile en quelques heures on est capable
de traiter des plusieurs centaines de
mètres de trottoirs ou d' espaces verts
aujourd'hui le travail est peut-être
plus fastidieux aussi mais les
jardiniers ont sans former régulièrement
la ville souhaite aussi sensibiliser le
public selon une étude du ministère de
la santé 30 % de la pollution des eaux
pourrait être causée par les usages non
agricoles à partir du 1er janvier 2019
les particuliers ne pourront plus
utiliser de produits phytosanitaires
enfin particuliers et non non
professionnel de façon plus générale
ils ont des impacts à la fois sur la
santé humaine sur l'environnement
et nous dans notre démarche plus
particulièrement au niveau de la
protection de la ressource
car on retrouve ses produits dans
l'ensemble du cycle de l'eau depuis le
1er janvier 2017 les communes sont
soumises à la loi la baie elle interdit
l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires sur les espaces publics